a hectic week of diplomacy in Asia
continues with a meeting between the
world's two most powerful men President
Biden who's been in Cambodia for a
summit with South Asian leaders is
buoyed by better than expected results
for his party in the midterm elections
China's Xi Jinping has also been
strengthened back home after being
confirmed as his nation's leader for
another five years tensions have been
running High the Chinese side still
angered by this Summer's trip to Taiwan
by the U.S speaker Nancy Pelosi on North
Korea the U.S believes China's not
bringing all of its influence to Bear to
reign in Kim Jong-un who's been
conducting a provocative series of
missile tests
[Music]
of course perhaps the most important of
issue of all that will be discussed is
the war in Ukraine China has not
condemned Russia but it's clearly
uncomfortable about the way its Ally has
been behaving
I spent more time than any other world
leader I know him well he knows me
there's no we have very little
misunderstanding we just got to figure
out where the red lines are and what we
what are the most important things to
each of us what all the countries of the
G20 gather here on Tuesday Russia's
President Putin will not be in Bali and
instead will be represented by his
foreign minister Sergey lavrov the U.N
Secretary General Antonio guterres who's
also on his way to Bali told me before
he left New York he didn't think there
was any possibility of a major
diplomatic breakthrough I believe still
a certain way to go peace is of course
the objective of us all peace in line
with international law and with U.N
Charter but I think that we are still
relatively away from it the U.S and its
European allies will want to use this
G20 to try and persuade countries like
China India Brazil and South Africa to
further isolate Moscow the war in Europe
casts a long shadow on the diplomacy
taking place here on the other side of
the world James Bay's Al Jazeera Bali